[Music]
hello everyone I'm Grandmaster Denis
Porsche and this is insane in the ingame
this time it's going to be the topic of
the bad bishops however when we talk bad
bishops
it's actually not clear where are those
bad bishops where can you spot them so I
thought I'm going to show you the first
game between vq gov and timofeyev
because this resembles a true chess game
where you can't really pinpoint where is
the bad Bishop so let's get into it so
the opening not necessarily not exciting
it is in English but again after let's
say 10 moves or even just 8 moves we can
tell and sum things up something is up
and that is that Bishop on c8 is pretty
bad and as if you're very much familiar
with openings in the French this is
called it the French Bishop often times
as you get this d5 we're going to show
you just in the beginning because it's
important here here and you often get
this terrible French bishop and just
like in the game of uno you would like
to throw away that Bishop if it was a
card but it ain't a card it's a verse
murthy piece on c8 and that's not a good
one so you're stuck with it for life
however the situation is not as bad here
in the English variation because it has
some chances to move around to d7 is
that an amazing place for that Bishop no
it's still quite terrible but that's the
best that you can get in the English
here so castles b3 it should be 2 Castle
rooks c1 rook c8
III Queen a5 4 now this looks like a
normal position
nothing really terribly spectacular
going on and it wouldn't even be really
sure which Bishop is bad at all like
this Bishop on these 77 they don't have
too much space that's true however
there's nothing wrong with them also
they're still a knight blocking this
bishop so there's still a debate going
on where is the bad Bishop a3 look at
the eight h3 b5 let's head over to the
endgame Knight d4 rook takes Queen 2 XE
1 so here let's stop for a second and
let's think with blacks brain a little
bit so at the moment Mike has more pawns
in the center that is correct that
should mean black is better here so if
we know that can we spot the very very
good move here so remember you're
talking about bad bishops you really
want to make sure your opponent's pieces
will get dampened I'll give you a little
bit of time to think about this and then
we'll continue
so at the moment White has a very very
good G to Bishop a decent Bishop on the
other side basically two wonderful
beasts on the two diag both of them are
strong hope that that is just not
working out that bad
arrow play anyways hating that arrow
play was chemo faith played rook c8
first off chasing away the Queen Queen B
1 and d5 a very strong move mind you
killing the scope of this Bishop on g2
now whose bishop is bad
in fact this bishop is not that good
anymore and as it's hitting a brick wall
of pawns that you can't really blast
through also who has more pawns in the
center black does in fact e 5 might be a
problem in the future as what as black
is starting to expand rook see one takes
mean take c1 and now I think as we're
reaching a queen and game with still
some minor pieces on the board it is
very important to remember not to give
up on getting more and more space so
again let's stop here and ponder how
could the black try to gain some more
space because at the moment black is
doing fine
obviously because he has two pawns in
the center
let's fight only having one supporting
that knight on d4 however more space the
better so let's think about it a little
bit before we continue
so if you would go a five that would
have one problem namely Knight f3 and
suddenly that stable structure you had
which blocked my g2 Bishop is opening up
so he five no longer is this is solid
construction and after Knight f3 I have
two pieces bothering that e5 pawn you
can go forward however then I come back
and no longer do you have this push of
e5 as pawns never go backwards sadly so
e5 is something black would consider
however after Knight f3 Knight d4 you
actually realize that would be a mistake
and would open up this bishop so in fact
here instead of e5 black could have
considered this move b4 y is b4 so good
well one thing it fixes upon on b3 and
stops this pawn push would be for so be
for a4 and eventually in b6 just
stopping knight c6 ideas eventually the
b3 pawn can become a target
after some maneuvering let's say here
Bishop e8 and an eventual 97 Knights c5
can be annoying as that pawn no longer
has any supporters but bike was trying
to be very solid and played Queen b6
Knight f3 trying to get that e5 square
Queen b7 for some reason he kind of
avoided that and played 92 Queen c6 and
after the exchange will stop for a
second and try to observe the situation
so at first blank everything's alright
everything's alright for black because
you've got the bishops why has the
bishops as well however you've got more
pawns in the center on the other hand
there's something that's very important
and probably underestimated by timofeyev
and that is the fact that this bishop is
entombed by its own pawns that's one
thing not the only thing and probably by
in itself wouldn't decide a game as you
would know in the French you don't win
automatically you still need a second
weakness it's not enough that your
opponent has a bad bishop and in this
case white has a potential for a passed
pawn now that Square on a4 is still very
tected however on the long-term that
will be an idea so in end games you
still have to remember which piece is
the strongest never forget that because
that might be handy in the future
here comes the king
you bring the king up to e2
now often people ask me why would you
play King f1 here what is the plan and
reality is vici gov just wants to make a
good developing move just like you
castle in the middle game in the end
game you naturally tend to bring the
king closer to your passer and also
closer to the center and here actually
black plays a good move according to the
engine but a move that in long term is a
little bit dubious from a practical
practical standpoint
so one of the things that black could do
is to copycat and just go king F faith
King e8 and King d7 just walk your King
up however I assume what vq gov would
have played as efore and get into an
endgame and the more pieces we exchanged
by the way the more likely the passer
will decide the game so instead of King
f8 meat we too have had to face
something more radical and that has a 94
now 94 is either a very good move or a
very bad one
why because after Knight takes e4 has
happened in the game D takes e4 you get
a doubled pawn on e6 any for now as I
told you already
according to the engine this is
completely fine but there's a
distinction between completely fine
and being very good for one side so just
because black is surviving in this
position it doesn't mean it is too
practical let's say if black decided to
go King f8 instead and play differently
with 97 probably he wouldn't be just
suffering but after 94 it is kind of
clear it's only white who can't play for
a when there are plenty of reasons for
that one of them is as mentioned already
before this a pawn can start running
second of all the scope of this Bishop
is actually getting better as now
there's a target on e4 not the same
thing with this Bishop on c6 which is by
all intents and purposes still bad
because it has to defend both the b5 and
the e4 pawns
so Knight takes e4 he takes e4 King ee1
so after a little bit of a detour and
taking on e4
he is just bringing in the king so now
you might be asking why is he bringing
in the king well he is bringing in the
king to support the pawn maybe sometimes
just to undermine that efore pawn but
it's also just a passing move getting
the king closer to the center
so now timofeyev plays Bishop d5 pretty
good move trying to attack the beep on
now here comes another important
question do we want to give up the beep
on for the e pawn
and reality is we don't want to why
because the only way to win this
position is to keep the majority on the
Queen side on the Kings side as you can
see you're even outnumbered so it's very
unlikely that you can break through
there before so even though this keeps
these pawns alive this break with a4 is
not that much on the table anymore
because one thing Bishop takes b4 is a
problem and also often times the bishop
can come back and aid the defense
however likes position should be solid
enough here at least the engine claimed
this is still drunk and I think
timofeyev made a slight inaccuracy here
can you spot the idea
so if you play the f5 here that is
exactly what Kimo FAF played very
logical defense all of these pawns
however a little bit too schematic when
instead probably g5 would make a lot of
sense oftentimes when you're defending
it's more important to realize what the
attacker has in mind than what you're
trying to do f5 is a logical idea over
defending the e4 pawn
however after Bishop f1 the ship c6 nh4
there will be some sort of bite and
eventually there could be a second
target on g7 after Bishop e2 h v moves
therefore if black would have started
with g5 you would have taken away that
important square from the pawn and after
f5 the game is more than likely to be a
draw because if they're here here we
should be to f5 there is no way through
if you ever try to bring the King in
there's always a Bishop f6
and this bishop is going to hold you up
in these critical breaking points of c5
and 85 so g5 would have been a very very
circumspect move by timofeyev and
probably we would have held as it would
stop this h4 move however he played at
five and oftentimes slight inaccuracies
lose you the game so so far we had and
we've seen two little inaccuracy
here black played Knight to e4 which is
not bad but not too practical take
stakes and here instead of g5 plate f5
and this is actually why technical play
is so tough to face because both of
these moves seem very logical however
they're just a little bit inaccurate
ship c6h4 as I said stopping g5 and
hoping to fix the weakness on g7 can
give seven Bishop e5 making sure and
clearing the passage for this King to
walk on up to d4 if you would just go
ahead and play King D - you could never
March up because there's a Bishop f6
check and your king is forced back you
go back I'm like just Waits so Bishop e5
is a strong move by V Q gov as he is
creating a passage through C 3 and D for
g6 king D - kinky 8th Bishop e2 again
these little dagger moves not
necessarily a threat to play h5 here
however it's annoying to face because in
a practical game it's kind of tough to
know whether h5 h6 is a real threat or
not so key buffet F decides to shut down
all the action however if you can think
about this for a second
it turns out this is just too much
why well one of the things is a four
still could be on the go at some woman
so if y manages to crash through with a
four they'll still be a be passers so
there's some winning chances there but
as we talked about it before probably
that's not enough by in itself however
there's many pawn weaknesses now you
can't really come close to the beep on
because this Bishop is guarding those
important squares
however we could have found a way
through let's see what he does
so he goes through with king c3 King D
for Bishop f8
so the sad truth for black is the
following
black will have to wait around with
Bishop e7 Bishop f8 because if you make
this unfortunate move of Bishop d8 the
King will seize the moment get to c5 and
attack the b5 pawn here and no longer
can you chase my King away and after you
lose the b5 font you lose the game check
and there's King a6 you are not mating
anybody and the b5 pawn is falling so
kima AF is just going to sit and wait
trying to hold the position by guarding
the c5 square ship f8 ship f4 and now
this is the big turning point this King
actually has another passage through a 5
and f6
you can check me because the same old
the same old King c5 King b6 and you
lose the pawn king the 8th a typical
move actually should deserve an
exclamation mark now if you don't know
this this is called the distant
opposition so Kimo fav make sure
whenever you play King e5 I will play
King g7 just setting up opposition and
on the surface this seems to work but
not after a long thought so King g5 King
g7 there's opposition or if black could
play one more move he would win the game
with checkmate
however it's white to move Bishop g5
check again you can go King d7 cuz King
f6 and you lose all of your pawns and
then the H bomb promotes it's got to go
King f7 so I really would love to ask
Magnus Carlsen whether this is a
fortress and the answer is of course
it's not so king f7 guarding the f6
square guarding the d6 and c5 square so
probably black was thinking it's a
fortress what would you want but the
problem that fortresses is the following
oftentimes you just don't have enough
moves and just run out of them you don't
have enough space to shuffle so let me
pause right here and give you the
opportunity for you to find this little
twist my video curve which will force
team of I have to show his hand
so if you found this little move of
Bishop f6 well congratulations
that is the move so Bishop f6 again just
taken away the possibility of Bishop g7
also just making sure and asking team of
F what are you going to do about it
ship d7 so timofeyev starts pushing this
bishop and back and forth hoping that
it's a fortress but the issue is the
following why it will get the Bishop to
b3 and you can't defend the b5 and e6
pawn the same time any longer you either
defend this guy or the b5 one if you
defend the b5 pawn then you're losing
the e6 pawn bishop d1 should be three is
coming ship c6 Bishop b3 Bishop d7 and
Bishop a2 and that's an important move
emphasizing the fact that right now you
no longer can just shuffle around you've
got to start winning through c8 and d7
the ship c8 so now
plaque is basically stuck you can't
really move the bishop much because
eventually you will allow the King to go
to the six and c5 you can't move the
King cause you drop the pawn so here me
to go finds this important maneuver of
Bishop d8 Bishop b6 and Bishop c5 and
now this is a big problem you can't go
Bishop g7 check asking these six and I
walk over to the b5 pawn and if you just
sit and wait I am going to go Bishop e6
Bishop c5 and King
six King c7 working these six King c6
winning the b5 pawn and after that if I
collect that pawn it's game over because
the b-pawn is just going to promote also
note that this terrible terrible bishop
on c8 is the cause of the downfall for
blacks position so King e8 played Bishop
g5 can you have seven Bishop f6 again
just emphasizing you still can't do
anything ship d7 Bishop b3 now he could
start doing this bishop d8 Bishop c6
Bishop c5 action but he figures this
bishop is not as useful on e2 then on b3
and do me to cough has the time to do
that yes he does so he plays Bishop b3
Bishop h6 Bishop d8 and here timofeyev
loses patience but this would have been
already winning so he gives up on Bishop
f8 King d6 now the king is coming closer
and the defense is almost at its
breaking point and here we to go plays a
very nice move which shows good
technique from the Russian player try to
spot this move
so probably we need to go realizing that
there could be some Bishop b2 Bishop a3
if he goes Bishop b6 he decides to
defend it in an unusual way it goes
Bishop e7 and you can't move the King
because you drop the bishop and Bishop
takes c6 is still very strong if you go
here I can just take on e6 and that is
just completely hopeless as you're going
to lose all of your pawns and the other
side so qff plays Bishop e5 check King
takes e5 King g7 and according to pawn
counts it says still even however the
difference between these two bishops is
going to decide the game
Bishop c2 there should be eight this
ship team on the ship c6 Bishop e2 just
changing the course and targeting the
beep on Bishop e8 Bishop f1 here
actually white is just literally messing
with black saying I can do anything I
can put my Bishop on h3 it doesn't
matter you still don't have a move ship
G to the ship c6 this should be 8 Bishop
e2 obviously you want the bishop closer
to this a4 break
ship c6 d1 we should be 8 but one thing
was sure me to go was making sure that
this bishop will be at the worse
position than he starts action now
realizing that this bishop is ideal on
d1 for the safe for break he starts
action now if you could go a 4 ba and
that pawn could become menacing Samhita
cough comes up with the idea of running
back with the King play a4 and King a3
very nice technique there by Nikita V to
go King b6 King c3 the King is actually
doing a home run plays a4
and thanking a3 here King the five not
letting in that King Bishop D 1 and a 4
b8 Bishop D 1 King B 5 King a3 and black
is actually a tempo short the King could
be on d3 there could be some hopes for
black to survive however King C 4 is too
late
Bishop takes a 4 and the endgame is
obviously that losing the b-pawn is just
way too fast
Bishop c8 the ship e8 and again remember
F v g6 and h5 some 30 moves ago well yes
that's the reason for the downfall for
black here now what is just going to be
able to pick up all of those pawns
if these pawns were still on g7 h6 there
still could be some hopes for some
fortress but not any longer this is
going to lose all of those pawns he
still tries but they're two pawns
running on both sides there's not much
chance for survival
h5 takes age 6 Bishop f5 fe3 b5 and
knowing that those two pawns by itself
would be too much for this Bishop after
let's say b7 takes 8 7 this's just
promoting and winning he goes for the
desperado move of Bishop c2 however this
is not going to save the game b6 takes
and this pawn is just way too fast ship
f3 Queens
e to check and f5 a very nice win by v2
Gough because he showed patience and
made sure that team of F I ran out of
moves
also remember to always probe your
opponent if they cannot make any moves
or in a tight spot that is kind of the
take away from this
game but apart from that this was the
most realistic way of looking at bad
bishops even though that Bishop on d7
didn't look that good it just turned out
to be really bad around move 60 that it
is actually a horrible Bishop on c6
talking about terrible bishops let's
look at this famous game by
hall-of-famer
Alexander ownership versus Danielle na
Radetzky so let's start over here from
this position so this is a classical
Catalan where black played Bishop d6 but
again you already can pinpoint there's a
problem there's a problem on c8 and that
problem child is going to be the cause
of a loss efore de 94 8 6 takes let's
get closer to this moment so we already
know this is a big problem there should
buy for Queen f4 and said as it may be
the best move for black in this position
was to play e5 or move earlier just e5
give up the pawn say take 6 but at least
you get your Bishop out just like in uno
you've got bad cards just try to throw
it away as quickly as possible but her
that scheme misses this big moment FINA
4p6
rook d1 which should be 7 and the next
move by Alex ownership is very very good
in fact is very technical we're not yet
in the endgame but he's already thinking
about it and he plays c5 saying that in
the long term your Bishop on b7
we'll be terrible completely out of play
and you can't really do anything with it
rook c8 rugby one again a sound solid
move you put your rooks on a future open
file also not letting me take c5
happened as that b7 Bishop would fall
you take would be seven and that's just
not good Bishop a8 does on eschew
consider taking on b6 no he's going for
exchanges as he knows in the future and
game this is going to be perfect for a
White Queen e7 how can you get into an
endgame
well exchange pieces Knight takes D
seven Queen d7 a4 again making sure that
there is no break through is not with b5
and BC would just run into DC where this
Bishop would still stare at the wall
rook the 8th Bishop f3 Queen e7 Queen
e5b takes e5 and I really hope you can't
guess what move honest you played in
this position
obviously Queen takes c5 now note that D
takes c5 is bad but he kind of says okay
that egg game must be very close to
winning so I'm just going to straight go
that direction and I don't mind if I
lose a bit of an advantage
it'll be just enough just look at that
bishop that will be the prime target in
the endgame Queen c7 this time now
Radetzky refuses rightfully so because
after takes takes this Bishop is just
very thankless as you can never play
Bishop d7 that's guarded by the rook and
because of the passivity of the black
pieces this is just a very very close to
winning for ownership Queen c7 and again
ownership here comes up with the great
idea of pushing this pawn up to a six
and you'll realize why is that so
brilliant a5 rugby eight sometimes you
could even consider will be five ideas
in the future let's say I'll play some
moves
kingi to rook c8 h four maybe ruby five
could be an idea and saying hey i just
really want to give you my pawn at least
my bishop is active and will be free and
if you go Queen c7 there's Bishop f3
check but honest shook make sure that
the ghost is still trapped in there no
would be five ideas no rugby five ideas
not giving any free moves for black
Queen d7 h4 very similar to the
timofeyev game against v2 gov very q gov
was making sure there's no way out
rook c8 in g2 slowly but surely going
forward Luke c7 rugby three and
dual-purpose move either rube db1 could
be an idea just to activate these rooks
or rogue d3 maybe with a potential d5
rate also defends this bishop so in fact
this has a triple purpose queen c8 black
is condemned to wait G for rook d7 g5
realizing that the dis Bishop you don't
really get any sorts of counter play he
can freely open up the Queen side and
these guys are more likely to jump on
the H file then these rooks on the 7 and
d8 h takes Queen c7 rookie three Queen
d6
and you don't have to ask on a schnook
twice he'll take on these six of course
look things d6 and now he closes the lid
on that Bishop does it cost upon well
it'll be worth the peace rook takes d4
takes takes a6 is coming rugby 3 first
just making sure that this bishop cannot
go out now route d8 is mandatory a six
and believe it or not this is completely
winning for white why well because that
bishop can't ever move in this game you
can't ever go to be 7 because you just
capture it at the pawn I'm obviously
never gonna take on c6 and if your rook
ever moves then there's rook b8 and that
bishop is just falling so you can see a
position after move 40 where black is
virtually stalemate it well not really
stalemate it but can't really move in
sort of a suits long can your faith we
should be for f5 exchanges are fine with
ownership
okay ch3 rug d3 and you can really move
the rook away because there's rook d7
you lose that pawn and then you lose the
game it's not that ski had to go for the
same game at five F for King g7 can you
have three here King III 'if I've a four
and after king d4 black resigned
rightfully so because he is actually
down the piece that Bishop cannot move
it is just staring at that pond and
there's nothing you can do so in these
cases it's very important that you
either sacrifice upon or do something
quickly before your Bishop get boxed in
however this is not the only game I
wanted to show you this is the last game
I wanted to show so let's start from
here this was one of Nakamura's favorite
openings but this time the first time he
played Magnus he kind of miss played it
played queen c8 hoping to change this
bishop however Magnus knows that this
bishop is the biggest problem child of
the position so he goes rook e1 we
should pay six bishops e2 and oftentimes
these little twists are not appreciated
by computers but the fact is in the long
run that bishop is just useless and the
potential target as we shall see
so rook e8 BC BC Bishop d8 so he is
trying to exchange the bishop via Bishop
d8 and Bishop c7 however the problem
child is still on the board meaning why
it should be better
rokay one very strong move just kind of
signaling nakamura that your bishop is
still going to be a big target ship c7
Queen d2 e 5d takes e5 takes takes and
what's actually faster
how Carlson does not mind to exchange
pieces why because he knows in the long
run this Bishop will be the problem
queen d4 rook e8 however as I mentioned
earlier in this lecture just because
your opponent has one bad piece will not
win you a game you definitely need to
create either a second weakness or an
attack so I'll pause right here just a
little bit so you can try to figure out
how you can create a second weakness
this game was from the Magnus
Invitational
so black is just about ready to get a
bishop on c4 and sort of consolidate
there's still some problems with the c6
spawn but it is readily defendable by
the queen and maybe in the future by the
rook not at the moment because there's
some Bishop f5 trickeries and you don't
want to fall for that
so trying to avoid Bishop c4 and also
creating some play he goes efore that is
Magnus now if you go Bishop c4 but it
could take take a 597 and f4 the spawns
start running and that can be very
annoying in this position or maybe e5
immediately and just f4 then actually
probably this one is even more accurate
and in a practical game facing f5 f6
does not look like fun
so now camera decided to take on e4 94
takes takes root d8 queen c3 Rogue d5
now if you take on e4
you will face lots of problems because
of the a6 bishop being misplaced if you
go g6 as that's the only way you can
stop the invasion of the Queen
there's Bishop b3 and if you go King g7
there's Queenie 5 check and with the
Queen closing in and you not having any
defenders on the King side is kind of
enough for this being a losing position
here cleanup 6 and there's just too many
threats on f7 g6 and c6 not to talk
about the fact that you're still kind of
pinned so not come over rightfully plays
rook at the 8th Queen c3 Rogue d5 and
this is something interesting here Alec
I'm the famous world champion would
probably go Queen e3 or try to go rogue
g4 and try to go for some
tax however Magnus is trying to minimize
the risk and put as much pressure or
positional pressure on his opponent as
possible so please Roque for this should
be seven takes takes and is this bishop
familiar to you yes it is the bishop
that we've seen in the ownership na
Radetzky game so white is much much
better here however it's still not clear
whether queen III Queenie 4 isn't
stronger than what Magnus played Magnus
played queen a5 saying you have problems
you have a bad bishop a target on c6
there should be ample winning chances
for me Ella kind on the other hand as
mentioned earlier either would go for an
attack or would go Queen III here
why because not only you have to deal
with this problem Bishop you also have
to deal with mating attacks on h7 and as
you might know Ella kind was a big fan
of attacking on both sides but this is
kind of question of style and causing
goes for Queen a5 it should be 7 in b6
g6 Bishop e4 so he's not interested in
checkmating he's just saying eventually
you are going to collapse and either
you're going to give up the c6 pawn or
you'll get into trouble because of your
misplaced Bishop rook d7 the ship f3
again this typical Magnus move defending
all of his pieces and getting ready to
probe his opponent maybe Bishop g4 or
even rook e1 just trying to get in in
the future or even Ruby one age 5
stopping that idea rook e1 Queen d8 a
good move by Nakamura he is trying to
exchange of the pieces because if we get
into a rockin game there's a high
probability that it should be drawable
for
Kimura in the 8:58 rookie seven and at
this moment actually Nakamura misses a
big chance and that's what I'm talking
about
Magnus display was a little bit dodgy
meaning not the most accurate so if he
was to go out for the win he could have
chosen Queen III which is probably a
little bit more accurate than the one he
chose so there's no question about it
Magnus is so much better
but if Nakamura were to defend much
better in this position he would get
drawing chances
he played Bishop a6 which was not the
most accurate should have played Bishop
c8 takes rook d1 checked which would
have been very important King h2 and
Bishop e6 the point being the rook will
get behind the passer where the other
look would love to be and after that the
King can walk up and they'll be ample
play against the C pawn is this still
dangerous for Nakamura definitely
but is it winning there is still some
chances here for black to hold but he
played Bishop a6
the ship takes c6 rooks e8 and the big
difference between rook d1 rook c1 and
rook c8 is that he can go for Luke II a
check and this is just winning for
Carlson takes takes King f8 Bishop c6h4
f4 these bones are still on white
squares which would mean that those
could be big targets for the bishop so
he is intending to fix these pawns on
those squares in g7 King F 2 F 6 so
Nakamura stirring trying to do the
contrary is trying to get all of his
pawns on dark squares and hope for a
defensive fortress shelter I'm not even
sure King e6 we should be for g5 king d
4 and again as we see time and time
again you want to have an active King in
an endgame and a passed pawn gf
there should be five guinea 4 and the
issue is that because this pawn is on h4
and not on h6 it is very hard to defend
that while stopping the C pawn so bishop
c8 king f4 and the issue is after this H
pawn is gone but we'll have two passers
and that's just too much and quite
enough for Carlsen to win the game
Bishop d7 G 3 a tricky move and a tough
one to face for Nakamura because if you
take on h3 white can't take on h4 and
not only he manages to get rid of the
h-bond he creates a passer and with
these two pastors though when is very
likely however there's still some tricks
as happens in the game as if black
manages to exchange this bishop for the
C pawn and bring the King to g7 it's a
draw because this is the long wrong
colored bishop so there's no way you can
win that so let's see how Magnus does it
King g3 can get fate h4 q g7 you can get
for King gate 6 bishop f3 now Bishop f3
is a very strong move why because it is
restricting his opponents counter play
not rushing with the C pawn because that
could have any some negative effects in
fact that would immediately drawn the
game as the king can get to h8 and it's
a complete draw Bishop f3 so he's just
making sure that a king can't come
forward and his plan is likely to be
to bring up the king and then start
pushing the C pawn with the help of the
bishop first he's going to get rid of
this Bishop from this diagonal let's see
what happens in g7 brings up the King
King d4 it's going this direction King
d5 Bishop g4 restricting not letting
this King get the d7 square also Bishop
d7 is no longer available for Nakamura
because that would just lead to an
exchange of pieces and these two pawns
would win the game ship d3 now as the
bishop moves he is ready to play c-65
ship ft we should be v c7 he gives up
the pawn but knows that that will divert
this King from its defensive duty and it
will not hold that important square on
g7 King b7 so this King will sprint over
to g7 pretty soon give me 5 H 5 the pawn
is running bishop c4h6
the ship d5 you can't take it because H
7 and it's promoting too quickly you
should page 7 we should be for takes
king c7 and it's still pretty sure
actually the game ended after King takes
at 4 but I do want to show you what
would have happened this is what would
have happened
King e5 here and the King doesn't get to
f8 in time and after King g7 King he ate
and King g7 the game is over because
either you drop the bishop or if you
move it the aged pawn promotes so I
really hope you guys enjoyed this
lecture about having bad bishops what to
look out for and how to probe for an
advantage you've seen both calls and
honest you can meet you go do so and I
really hope you enjoyed this lecture
you
[Music]